hello and welcome to the tenth
fundamental investing with the use of
programming tutorial where we left off
of showing you all how to further screen
a batch of data that we don't to
continue running through the whole huge
set right so in this case you know
instead of running through 3000 bits of
3000 tickers you can generate kind of a
screened list that is very loose but yet
kind of whittles down this list so the
absolute absurdity companies aren't
included that way every time you want to
look through them you're not getting
just crazy stuff that you it's just
wasting your bandwidth and Yahoo's
bandwidth so so that's how to start
screening stocks and then what we did
here this one was basically with a bunch
of two's and now this one required a
price to book of one instead of a price
to book of two but it allowed the rest
so with that we generated here all of
these companies met that requirement and
then at the end it printed out a very
small list or a much smaller one anyway
of companies and if we look through this
list pretty quickly we see that a fam is
at least a decent one it's it's PG R its
forward PG righties it's one point two
eight so the goal is really a one but
one point two eight not so bad
and you know the debt-to-equity pretty
love trailing p/e is pretty low-priced
book under one that's good so we're
pretty we're pretty happy with this
company again it doesn't mean all of the
fundamental requirements however so just
keep that in mind I'm not suggesting
anybody goes out and buys a fan by any
means please heed the warning in front
of the video but let's say let's say
we're interested we want to know more
about a fan right so which is almost
family so what do we do at this point
right once we've found all this
information where what might we do now
well at this point I mean we can look
through this list and really probably
whittle is lose down a little bit more
and maybe require that the equity ratio
that is a not not available but also
under 40 or something like that would
knock out quite a few of these companies
immediate
so this list would really be like 10
company spirit or something like that so
you could probably do that and even get
this little smaller and at that point
you really can't go through this stuff
by hand there's it's not as necessary
that you use a program anymore but so
for example let's let how would we do
that though there's one more thing I
still want to show you guys as far as
acquiring this data so let's say a fam
we're interested to know more about a
fan so what we can do is come over to
yahoo.com and drag it over here this was
that Navy Yard shooting I guess anyway
finance click on that and we'll just put
in a fam and can you believe summers
withdraw I just can't believe that
happened but anyway really thought he
was for sure gonna get it okay so we
find a fam and then to get to some
interesting information for a fan let's
go to the income statements the next
thing we kind of want to know is what
are the financials for this company like
what's the bottom line is are we are we
doing good you know with this company or
what like why is generally if it's
undervalued there's a good reason but
many times they're there it's just like
I don't know poor sentiment and
emotional kind of stuff it can lead to
very undervalued companies so anyway
check it out their income statement we
can view both quarterly and we'll see
that quarterly goes back only a year
fairly level but again they're here
they're kind of slowly chipping away at
earnings and let's take the further back
approach and let's check out all the
annual data here and let's go over so
this one goes back obviously three years
so December 31st 2012 2011 2010 but
again we can see that their earnings are
actually slowly in decrease so that
would kind of make us shy away a little
bit but again a value investing and kind
of the more bigger principles of value
investing is that we kind of we you shy
away from
speculation so we're not looking at you
know we're not growth investors here and
we're not momentum investors here you
know so the fact that it's decreasing in
profits isn't necessarily a a something
that's gonna make us check this off the
list at the same time we want to know
now generally you want to look more like
five years back if not 10 years back and
if we kind of browse around here on
Yahoo we see that whoa there's really no
easy way like how do we get further back
data well I've kind of looked around
online and there is really no at least
free source of historical either
quarterly or annual earnings data so
that kind of sucks right and you can buy
it and usually you have to buy it in
batches and it's you know in the
hundreds if not thousands of dollars for
this financial data but luckily there is
kind of a way around paying for that
historical data don't think that many
institutions are using this I bet
they're actually buying the data but you
can't do this so what can you do to get
around this well you can go to Google
and either type in Wayback Machine or
you can go to their website it is let me
just go back to the home page here this
is their home page it's archive.org and
then slash web slash web PHP and here
what the idea of this is is it basically
the cache pages right they visit these
pages and they just save all of the HTML
and then so what you can do is you can
type in old internet pages in the year
and kind of visit the website from like
way back in the day all right so we go
to Facebook Wow
Facebook you're pretty lame anyway due
to robots.txt Facebook won't let us
parse now that's great Facebook thank
you anyways gonna show you guys an old
version of Facebook but I guess we can't
so anyway back to Yahoo so let's say we
want to know like okay well this this
one was only going back to 2010 but what
if we come up into our address bar here
copy this come over to the Wayback
Machine and paste in a fam
so hit show all hopefully that'll work
okay so we can see with the annual
results of a fan it actually hasn't even
pulled anything from a fan in 2013 but
we do have something for 2012 and then
we have a gap of about you know two
years here but it looks like we were
obviously missing December here December
here and December here but let's click
on this one because this one is missing
this December so I bet this one starts
at this here this here so I bet it will
line up just perfectly so at the moment
again we've got December 12 2012 all the
way back to 2010 what we need is
starting at 2009 and prior so can we do
that well let's click on this 2012
version and you like you click here and
then it gives you like a calendar and
then if it's got like a little blue on
it that means it's got a page from that
day so we can click on that and wait for
it to load and once it loads sure enough
we you know we already had this data and
but we didn't have 2009 right so now
we've got the 2009 data which shows they
were actually making you know from 2009
to 2010 actually made it quite a healthy
profit right hey they went from 158 to
182 so now what were kind of curious
okay well what about 2008 all right can
we get some data on oh wait so we come
back over to here and we're not here
sorry go back over here right so click
on this one yeah it looks like okay cool
oh man I didn't give us hmm what's this
one 2012 and then before that is 2009
but we don't have anything so we're
missing one bit of data right for that
the December 31st 2009 and one moment we
actually maybe even get around that but
if you look at a 5 ok they were making
about 36 mil then they may you know
almost 45 million then almost 70 million
and then we could see before they
actually dropped down at least by oh
nine back to the 50s but now and then
again now recently they're making much
larger digits so actually on a large
enough time scale you know this company
is actually still in growth so that is
something that you you want to kind of
keep in mind that in again you know for
fundamental investors and value
investors I mean we're not even looking
we're not like looking to buy and hold
it for a year you're looking to buy and
hold for ten years or something like
that right and on a ten-year scale this
company is actually looking pretty solid
and we could continue going back as we
go back again on 2007 right so we've got
a seven oh six oh five what if we want
to go back even further can we do it
let's try it then we go even back to oh
four where they were making even less
money so again growth still growing okay
so but what about what was the one that
we're missing I think we were missing
was it 2009 or 2008 I can't even
remember now you know I think we were
missing a the the December 24 December
31st 2009 now we got a no.9 there so
maybe we're missing oh wait surely we
would have a wait here though oh I see
well that's weird why we I'm wondering
well we don't have an OE in this poll
because it pulled it on Jan 3rd 2009
maybe the earnings just hadn't come out
yet
so I think this is like the quarter of
the period ending so earnings maybe
hadn't come out so so how will we get
around that well we could instead click
on quarterly data and I think the way
this website works is that a lot of
students yes so right so we want the
2008 data so if you look well you can
track their earnings in the quarterly
cuz it looks like we've got a poll here
and a poll here so we might be able to
just just add it up right so so I think
this is a kind of a good example of you
know what you can do to get around these
requirements to buy the data
and most of the most of the companies
have enough crawls where you don't even
have to do this but again it with zoomed
out version of this company and I think
that in using like Wayback Machine you
get the older data to me this company
actually looks pretty good from a from a
value investor standpoint and based
purely on their data I don't know too
much about almost family incorporated
but I'll probably actually even look
into this company myself so anyway but
again that's not a suggestion to buy any
securities or anything don't buy this
stock based on what I've said so anyway
so that's kind of a good way to go about
getting the historical earnings data for
companies now obviously you could also
buy this stuff
I think Thomson Reuters will sell it to
you you can contact them it's probably
in the two-three hundred maybe five
hundred dollar range to get the data you
can also at least what I did is I just
pulled this data with a program and just
went through every company and just
pulled all of the historical data and
then compiled it that way I didn't have
to go through this stuff by hand and I
might eventually put out a tutorial and
how to parse wayback machine I'm just
not sure I want to do that to wayback
machine because it creates probably and
unnecessary load for them so haven't
really decided if I want to show a
tutorial on that or not but maybe I'll
do that if there's enough interest in it
maybe I'll do it as far as other forms
of investing or fundamental investing
are concerned you know you might be
looking for different stats maybe you
want something from other pages so maybe
you want you're looking for something
other thing that key stats are you know
you might be looking for other stats you
should that you should already have that
pretty down pat even if you wanted other
stats you should be able to kind of
figure it out from the program that
we've shown so far but obviously you
know you parse anything over here you
can parse analyst opinions you can parse
all of this stuff and they've got cash
flow you could parse other
pages and stuff so anyway you can set up
a program to do a lot of this kind of
research for you so just like parsing
wayback machine if anybody if there's
enough requests for something that I
haven't really covered fully as far as
pulling data from Yahoo Finance if
there's enough requests for it I'll just
make a video on showing you how to do it
I think this kind of series is pretty
much wrapped up at this point there's
not too much new I could show you guys
as far as parsing data from a table is
concerned and as far as getting the
historical data that's how you can do it
you should be pretty much all set and
then you can start doing a security
analysis really on the company and
deciding what your value of the company
is versus you know what these figures
have said so anyway that should pretty
much cover it for fundamental investing
all that from hearing and you can do all
kinds of stuff that you you know
whatever kind of stuff you want to do
from here mostly we've just kind of used
the computer to help us in the research
process and find eligible companies so
hopefully you guys have enjoyed this
series as always thank you for watching
thanks for your support your
subscriptions and until next time